good evening bail for an accused serial
rapist in the U.S illegally has been
reduced to 30 thousand dollars thanks
for joining us here at six I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus this a story
the eight news now investigators have
been closely following Vanessa Murphy
explores the decision to judge mate even
after several women have spoken up
Carlos Nava is accused of victimizing
women and committing violent sexual
assaults against them with a knife while
he's in the U.S illegally but according
to a judge he poses little to no danger
to the community so she granted him a
bail he could afford
did you commit these assaults only eight
news now was there as Carlos Nava was
taken into custody again last November
at the Regional Justice Center in
downtown Las Vegas this was moments
after he appeared in court and as he'd
learned he's accused of being a serial
rapist
members of our community since 2003. the
case began last July when a sex worker
told Metro Police Nava sexually
assaulted her while holding a knife to
her detectives say they reviewed
surveillance video and tracked down Nava
who had 17 pairs of women's panties in a
backpack possibly as trophies
investigators then connect him to a
string of five sexual assaults against
sex workers since 2003 one of the
alleged victims 16 years old Four Women
testify in front of the grand jury
prosecutors say three are DNA matches a
fourth woman identifies Nava he's
indicted Bayless said at half a million
dollars then judge Christy Craig drops
it to thirty thousand with high-level
electronic monitoring in this order
we've obtained judge Craig cites reasons
like Nava has a job Family Ties and has
lived in Las Vegas since 2004 but as the
8 news now investigators previously
uncovered Immigration and Customs
Enforcement says Nava has re-entered the
U.S illegally multiple times since 2002.
he's been arrested for battery and
domestic violence and the last known
time he was removed from the U.S by
authorities was in 2020. records show
the day after judge Craig's decision
Nava posts Bond but as of Friday he
remains in custody while judge Craig
decided Nava could be released it
appears there's now an immigration hold
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
the Clark County district attorney Steve
Wolfson believes the thirty thousand
dollar bail is too low and the judge
made the decision against prosecutors
quote strenuous objection in fact they
went on to say that NABA is a Flight
Risk and a danger to the community his
next hearing is set for April